Ні, це не війна. Але підготовка до потенційних конфліктів.
Джонатан Окс вже півроку перебуває тут, на півничному сході Польщі.
Зовсім близько до російського кордону. І дуже далеко від дому у Сполучених Штатах.
Раніше він двічі був у Іраку. І там, і тут його професія – танковий навідник-оператор.
Це абсолютно по-різному. Як день і ніч.
Ірак був місцем бойових дій, там було надзвичайно багато роботи у межах нашої місії.
Тут ми сконцентровані на тренінгах з нашими друзями.
Тут нас ніхто не ненавидить. Ми працюємо з нашими партнерами по НАТО.
Окс - один з майже тисячі солдатів НАТО з різних країн світу,
які мають тут продемонструвати, на що здатні війська.
Привід  - Польща святкує своє 20-річчя членства в НАТО.
Це демонстрація сили і для польського президента.
Тут розміщені сили швидкого реагування НАТО, щоб захистити нас та особливо - східний фланг Альянсу.
Я сподіваюсь, що ця присутність дедалі зростатиме.
Багато поляків вбачають у Росії загрозу -
особливо після військової агресії проти України та анексії Криму.
Саме через це, задля відлякування супротивника, США розмістили на східному фланзі НАТО
додаткові війська.
В Польщі - до п’яти тисяч американських солдатів.
Від присутності американських військових
має зиск і це маленьке польське містечко Ожиш поблизу бази НАТО.
Окс та інші солдати часто сюди навідуються.
Те, що до кордону з Росією звідси менше ста километрів, Окс не вважає загрозою.
Ні, я б не сказав, що це якийсь тягар для нас. Ми - партнери НАТО.
Ми тут, щоб навчатися протистояти будь-якій загрозі.
Йдеться про будь-яку загрозу.
Коли ми сто років тренуємось і нічого поганого не стається, це і є гарне тренування.
Багато людей у місті почуваються більш захищеними відтоді,
як сюди прийшли американські солдати.
Не бояться відтоді Росію і в улюбленому ресторані Окса.
Ми менш боїмося, що вони прийдуть сюди або що з літаків тут можуть щось скинути.
Так, ми вважаємо, що можемо покластися на американців.
Ми вважаємо, що вони допоможуть нам у випадку конфлікту з Росією.
Протягом багатьох років поляки вимагають створити постійну американську базу в Польщі.
Донині цього не сталося.
Окс незабаром теж  поїде назад до США.
Він особливо з нетерпінням чекає зустрічі зі своєю маленькою донькою.
До нині він бачив її лише раз після народження.